matthew boyd on for the fourth time and
he's been getting roughed up he's in
double digits and pitches something you
just don't want to do right out of the
chute
timmy drive to left field he waited him
out and bring him home one nothing sucks
tim anderson
a long fruitful first at bat jim
anderson who is in line for a big day
today
silences the crowd well actually more
silent than they normally would be by
hitting one out and the sox lead one to
nothing tim knows he got it as soon as
it left the bat
that's a good feeling
eloy jimenez rocks this ball to right
field and it is gone
back to back in the first inning you
didn't even take a swig of your drink
yet and it's two zip two hitters two
homers two to nothing sucks here's
jonathan scope one for three with a run
scored last night that one hit the lone
hit in the series thus far
launches one to center robert on the run
looking up still going back that ball's
gone into the bushes for jonathan scope
chicago hit two solo homers in their
first
jonathan scope answers right back with
number four of the year we got one of
those too right chef i know you're gonna
you're gonna hit a couple well we're
gonna answer right back tim anderson has
the at-bat of the ball game so far uh
ten pitch home run
so first pitch here he strokes down the
line left field corner there she rolls
and tim breaks into second base tough
time digging it out for stewart so tim
takes third
stewart didn't raise his hands and say
it was stuck so tim decides to go slip
and slide into thirds yeah he helps andy
fletcher because he figures he's there
nobody's tagged him he's safe and he's
just reminding andy fletcher that
yep i'm at third and nobody has tagged
me jose abreu rbi chance ground ball
right side they were in the wrong spot
for that puppy though and jose drives in
tim it's 3-1 abreu and jimenez are
leading the way
that could be
by the end of this 60-game season the
lowest exit velocity rbi of the year
third straight inning the tigers
have had a runner at second base vic de
reyes trying to pick him up
struck him out and that went off the mid
of mccann that allows candelaria to move
up and reyes is going to be safe at
first
grayson griner sends one
center is that going to get up the gap
it will both runs will score grayson
grinder trots into second with a two-run
double his first hit of the season ties
the game scope's home run was center
field right harold castro's double was
to left so the opposite way and now you
see grayson greiner using that part of
the field willie get out turns out
see you later
a two-run blast and the tigers are in
front what a
2020 debut for willy castro huh
that's a way to step in here absolutely
today the fifth time in sox history
that the teams led off the game with
back-to-back home runs
in center field tim anderson is a double
shy
of the cycle base is loaded two out luis
robert
first pitch hunting high fly ball right
field back to the warning track it's off
the wall for robert
a ringing wall ball one is in second one
home here comes the final one and
carnazione scores
clear him luis robert and the sox lead
six to five
mazzara to center field castro back it's
over his head it's rolling all the way
to the wall and the sox dugout gets
riled up again as nomar mazara belts a
double on a 7-5 lead
winner gets the series here socks and
tigers
foul ball left side eloy over there and
he ends up in the net again
yeah that's one of the things that he
might want to take out of the equation
try to get the ball
if you can't
try to stay on your feet i know it's a
good effort
and he's been fortunate that's the third
time he's gone into the neck and he's
feeling the effects of it gregory soto
will work the ninth for the tigers
you got a magnifying glass that's what
you need to find the numbers against
soto this year and a walk to mccann come
on now bear down we got a couple outs
keep us in there we got a chance here's
the two-two
down
soto got a little trouble took him 25
pitches to get through it
but he strikes out the chicago side in
the ninth seven five sox with the lead
and it's close in time
alex kolomay comes out four for four in
saves column against jacoby jones that
was a cutter that trailed inside a
little bit and in right field mazara
camps to make the catch for round number
one willie castro three for three
including a home run that gave the
tigers a fleeting lead in the fourth two
and two on the way
another cutter and it's popped up tim
goes over and leaves it to robert two
down two down nico goodroom
one two
one more cutter and that's all
sox win the series
seven to five after losing the opener
two in a row coming home